[Musik]
ganz bayern sind heute ungefähr zehn
millionen wahlberechtigte aufgerufen
ihre stimme abzugeben um einen neuen
landtag zu wählen
und wir wollen jetzt mal nicht hören was
die menschen hier in münchen umtreibt an
diesem besonderen tag an dem die csu
vielleicht die größte schlappe ihre
geschichte erleben könnte und ihren
allein herrschaftsanspruch in bayern den
sie auch hat und behalten will
womöglich verlieren könnte und in eine
koalitionsregierung gezwungen werden
könnte auf dem festgelände herunter csu
vorbei und dann muss man schauen was
sagen koalition das kommt es wird sehr
spannend
naja ich hoffe dass dem server und dem
seehofer eins auf den deckel gegeben
wird
warum haben sie das weil beide
eigentlich nicht glaubwürdig sind
und was würden sie sich für bayern
wünschen welche veränderungen erhoffen
sie sich ja auf jeden fall dass
migration schon im vordergrund steht
aber als ja das hoffentlich einfach
gelder dafür genommen werden um
migration stattfinden zu lassen und ich
bin eigentlich dafür dass man leute
ruhig nach deutschland holen kann und
dass wir in öffentlichen frieden damit
leben können das ganze schlamassel
termin seehofer
es gibt sich in bei ihren akkus anzüge
nicht
[Musik]